et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc valérie rabault bonjour beaucoup
d'être avec nous députée de tarn et
garonne vous présidez le groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est bonjour stéphane
bonjour qui dirige le bureau parisien du
journal ouest france on commence par la
politique et ce résultat de la primaire
des écologistes et donc yannick jadot
qui représentera les écologistes à la
présidentielle
résultat au terme d'une primaire très
serrée 1 51% des voix pour yannick jadot
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce résultat
est ce que c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour les socialistes et pour anne
hidalgo vous soutenez écoutez moi je
n'ai pas commenté ces primaires je ne
commenterai pas plus ce que j'observe le
juste c'est qu'effectivement
il y a des dans le fond il ya deux blocs
au sein des écologistes avec une vision
plus radical que l'autre est que de
cette primaire a certes permis un
résultat on va pas le nier mais elle n'a
pas permis de créer une majorité et ça
c'est un petit peu la différence c'est à
dire que une élection présidentielle la
clé d'une élection présidentielle pour
tout candidat c'est cette capacité à
rassembler d'abord rassembler celles et
ceux qui nous soutiennent et puis
beaucoup plus largement et à l'issue de
cette primaire on voit qu'on a un
résultat très très c'était déjà le cas
au premier tour puisqu'il y avait quatre
quarts en quelque sorte et là on a deux
moitiés quasiment équivalente donc cette
capacité à rassembler
aujourd'hui il ne l'a pas aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de magie grâce à lui qu'il ya
pas de majorité très très nettes qu'ils
se soient dits légers quand on est à 51
% sur une primaire c'est à dire que à la
primaire normalement votre les personnes
qui partagent vos idées
peut pas dire qu'une grande large
majorité se soit dégagé mais du coup
vous pensez que ça va ça va être facteur
de division au sein des verts maintenant
mais ils ont du mal à se rassembler je
ne m'aime je vais pas commenter chez les
verts ça
ce que j'observe c'est que une élection
présidentielle c'est pas une élection
législative une élection présidentielle
c'est la capacité à rassembler une
grande majorité de français et des
français qui ne partagent pas 100% de
vos idées donc quand vous êtes au sein
d'une formation politique même élargie
avec des personnes qui à priori partage
vos idées vous vous êtes censé
rassembler très largement voilà
j'observe que ça n'a pas été le cas en
parlant des sociétés puisque maintenant
on connaît candidat des écologistes on
connaît la candidate des socialistes y
aura un vote le 14 octobre mais a priori
ça sera ça sera un hidalgo que vous
souhaitez nerfs vous étiez à rouen à ses
côtés du coup yannick jadot c'est quand
même une ligne écologistes qui est très
proche de celle de yannick jadot est ce
que du coup pour vous c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle d'avoir finalement deux
candidats avec deux lignes c'est
similaire elles sont pas nous nous
portons unis social démocrate sociale
écologiste d'ailleurs qu'on marche sur
deux jambes
on est là déjà dont ne marche que sur
une obole jamais le progrès en tout cas
l'écologie au progrès social au progrès
économique s'est transformé l'économie
sans détruire de valeur de valeur mais
de la valeur ajoutée pour notre pays
c'est une transformation qui s'inscrit
dans le progrès mais c'est quand on
parle de transformation on donne le
point d'arrivée mais on explique aussi
la manière d'y parvenir et oui j'étais
avec anne hidalgo vendredi dernier au
dernier meeting de la fiole ça à cologne
effectivement l'allemagne est concerné
par une grande transformation de son
industrie en croissance de 25% de sa
richesse nationale et donc tout le débat
c'est le comment comment on arrive à
obtenir à réaliser cette transformation
il ya quand même des parallèles entre
autres yannick jadot et les partis
socialistes entre ce qui défend il vous
avait déjà il ya déjà eu un ticket en
2017 entre yannick jadot et benoît hamon
est ce que est ce que le fait que ce
soit lui qui sort de la primaire c'est
pas une chance quelque part on ne sait
pas est ce que ce n'est pas plus facile
de dialoguer avec lui en vue d'une
éventuelle union de la gauche et des
verts le dialogue il a toujours existé
j'espère je souhaite qu'il continuait à
ce qu'ils aient pas pris facile avec
yannick jadot cash dit sandrine rousseau
j'en sais rien voilà vont poser une
question je ne sais pas vous répondre je
n'en sais rien à me souhaiter qu'elle
exigeait pour aboutir à quoi est ce que
mes mains je vais vous dire à quoi là on
est dans une phase jusqu'en décembre où
toute l'offre politique va être présenté
va pouvoir être débattue chacun va
pouvoir poser ses idées dans le débat
politique évidemment halles à partir de
la fin de l'année début janvier il va
falloir qu'il y ait une stratégie une
stratégie ça suppose un rassemblement
pour que je souhaite la candidate de la
gauche puisse arriver au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle c'est tout
l'objectif donc vous voyez bien que mon
nez on a une phase pour l'instant qui
est de dire on pose un certain nombre de
questions d'idées sur la table
l'élection présidentielle c'est à la
fois parler des français mais parler de
la france et je pense que cette notion
là il faut pas qu'elle disparaisse du
débat qui va s'ouvrir en tout cas qui
est en train de s'ouvrir actuellement
moi j'ai été trés dans la campagne de
2010 est je constate que le candidat qui
a été élu n'a pas beaucoup parlé de la
france et on voit bien qu'elle se fait
déclasser sur la scène internationale
vous avez vu l'épisode des sous marins
on va parler de tout ça mais je devais
mais ça c'était très important très très
abondantes notamment parce que notamment
parce qu'il ya des forces d'extrême
droite qui tente de préempter ce sujet
avec des solutions qui sont radicalement
opposés à tout ce qui a été notre
histoire tout ce qui a été la tradition
et même la construction de la république
justement donc vous dites jusqu'en
décembre on débat d idées chacun est un
peu dans son couloir et chacun expose
ses idées mais en janvier il faudra bien
se réunir si on veut peser dans cette
présidence ça veut dire qu'il n'y aura
pas et anne hidalgo meriem ben heine
phase c'est pas une phase statique il ya
une dynamique qui s'enclenche donc je
peux pas vous dire ce que ces dynamiques
donnera à la fin décembre mais est-ce
que les algues au pourrait se rallier à
yannick jauzion est yannick jadot ses
fans le rappeler c'est bien rallier à
benoît hamon en 2017 est ce que là ça
peut être un peu l'effet inverse c'est
moi vous voulez toujours compte ce sont
des étapes et bien là on est dans une
étape qui va jusqu'en décembre où toute
l'offre politique est mise sur la table
ce qui va permettre à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens d'en prendre connaissance et
je l'espère de créer une dynamique
autour d'anne hidalgo la dynamique et
commence assez bas pour l'instant un
sondage crédite anne hidalgo de 2 4% de
l'intention de vote aubry vite alors
c'est il faut pas écouter les sondages
partir bas ça va monter très fort c'est
inquiétant vous soyez dans l'équipe anne
hidalgo est la seule à avoir une équipe
autour d'elle vous l'aurez observez vous
avez dans son équipe michael delafosse
qui était parti à 7% dans les sondages
et qui a rendu à montpellier mais
montpellier
si je prends le combat si je compare
avec l'allemagne olaf scholz était donné
à 8 et il est premier il arrive en tête
au terme du scrutin dimanche qu'il
mettait beaucoup d'espoir dans ce qui
s'est passé aux législatives en
allemagne
beaucoup d'espacé que je fais partie de
ceux qui voient beaucoup le spd alors en
dehors des caméras j'entretiens des
relations assez proche avec eux où on
débat peu moins pendant la période de
collines et donc j'ai pu observer de
manière très proche ce qui s'est passé
en allemagne j'ai vu aussi les doutes
qui existait au sein du spd au moment du
départ âge de la campagne et j'ai vu
aussi ce qui a donné une dynamique de
campagne je peux vous dire que le
candidat olaf scholz que j'ai vu
vendredi ce n'est pas forcément celui
d'il ya deux ans avec qui j'avais des
battus c'est à dire que il ya eu une
vraie transformation donc vous pouvez
pas éluder ce qu'est une dynamique de
campagne on vous pensez encore pouvoir
gagner à messieurs vous disiez vous
lisiez un instant qu anne hidalgo la
seule qui ait une équipe autour d'elle
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il y aura
qu'une seule candidate à la primaire
interne des socialistes 14 octobre on
sait rien puisque chaque candidat
éliminé d'octobre les dépôts de
candidatures voilà ce que sera la seule
à votre avis aujourd'hui non je suis là
madame soleil on verra bien vous avez
quand même jour des noms mais chaque
candidat mais vous savez en politique on
peut très bien déposer sa candidature le
7 octobre à 23h59 q comment voyez vous
que je sache il ya peut-être d'autres
candidats je n'en sais rien allez on va
parler du reste de l'actualité il ya
beaucoup de sujets dans le reste de
l'actualité sur lesquelles on voudrait
vous entendre et d'abord la france qui
hier a décidé de réduire fortement le
nombre de visas permettant de voyager
des pays du maghreb vers la france c'est
une décision qui est justifiée par le
refus de l'algérie de la tunisie du
maroc de fournir en nombre suffisant des
laissez passer consulaires ce sont ces
documents qu'ils sont indispensables au
retour dans leur pays des clandestins
que la france veut refoulé gérald
darmanin a répondu hier devant les
députés à une question sur ce sujet
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de cette
décision du gouvernement elle est
comment dire le gouvernement un peu une
stratégie diplomatique à deux vitesses
c'est à dire avec l'effort il a tendance
à faire en sorte que la france s'écrase
je pense à la question des sous marins
et avec goût la france l écraser sur
cette question non c'est une humiliation
on en a eu d'autres un des humiliations
ces derniers temps mais là c'est une
grosse humiliation quand même avec quand
même des questions stratégiques sur le
fait qu'il puisse y avoir du transfert
de technologie sur le nucléaire enfin là
on est on est sur des lignes de crête
vis-à-vis du traité de non-prolifération
donc je suis très inquiète et je trouve
que c'est une humiliation et puis d'un
autre côté il veut tenter de nous
montrer que voilà on est on est très
forts avec des décisions qui
s'inscrivent dans un climat politique
pré présidentielle là on est dans la
présidentielle sur cette décision la
presse on est un peu dans la
présidentielle à
droite
toute façon je pense que je demanderai
de la réciprocité de la part d
une réciprocité moi je suis pas de
difficultés là dessus j'observe juste
qu'avec les états unis et l'australie il
ya quand même eu zéro réciprocité je
sais un mot sur la crise et sous marins
puisque vous en parlez christian jacob
il disait dimanche qu'il espérait que
richard ferrand prenne une initiative au
nom de l'assemblée nationale pour qu'on
y voit plus clair sur ce qui s'est
réellement passé vous aussi vous le
souhaitez oui oui je soutiens cette
demande je soutiens si vous souhaitez
quoi une commission denquête commission
denquête évidemment qui permet
d'attendre toute l'assemblée n'a je
pense que ce serait à tout à l'honneur
du président ferrand de le demander
c'est ce qui s'est passé est très grave
à la fois parce que la france a été
humiliée et à la fois parce qu'on est
sur une question aussi de transfert de
technologie alors plus ou moins on sait
pas si elle en comptera sur une question
nucléaire et qui du coup pose des
questions vis-à-vis du respect du traité
de non-prolifération des armes
nucléaires
les hausses des prix de l'énergie le
gouvernement va rallonger le chèque
énergie est ce que c'est une une bonne
bonne réaction à la flambée des prix de
l'énergie alors sur ciac énergie je
rappelle que donc oui ça cette mesure là
s'il fallait faire mais oui il fallait
faire
je regrette qu'il n'ait pas fait plus
tôt puisque il avait eu l'opportunité de
le faire dès 2018 quand nous nous avions
proposé de doubler le chèque énergie et
nous avions proposé une seconde chose
qui était de 10 ans jules sept chèques
énergie ne concerne que le chauffage
c'est à dire sur votre facture
d'électricité de gaz ou de fuel par
contre le chèque énergie ne concerne pas
les carburants qui eux aussi flambent et
vous avez aujourd'hui plus de 14
millions de français qui prennent leur
voiture tous les matins pour aller
travailler parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
transports en commun et sur ses 14
millions vous en avez 8 5 millions qui
en moins de 1700 euros par mois donc
quand vous avez une facture de carburant
qui représente 250 300 euros sur un
salaire à 1700 il vous on voit bien que
l'enfant reste l'impact est majeur
cette proposition là a été refusée pour
la majorité et le gouvernement je le
regrette mais il me paraît indispensable
de donner aussi un signal à l'ensemble
de ces français qui ont qui prennent la
voiture sont pas de transports en commun
comme c'est très simple de vérifier sur
le trajet votre trajet entre votre
domicile et votre travail si oui ou non
vous avez des transports en commun donc
sur ce point là eux vont se prendre
l'impact de la hausse des carburants de
plein fouet il ya un autre sujet en
creux derrière cette histoire de
d'énergies fossiles dont les les prix
flambent c'est celui du nucléaire est ce
que est ce que c'est pas le moment de
regretter d'avoir fermer fessenheim non
mais c'est le moment alors ça c'est ça
ça pose la question du positionnement
aussi d'edf et sur la scène sur la scène
européenne il vous aura pas échappé que
sur les
340 térawattheures que produit edf via
le nucléaire et n'a plus d'une centaine
et peut-être même la totalité qui sont
conditionnés par un prix ou enlevant à
42 euros alors que ça nous coûte plus
cher à produire donc ça c'est quand même
une disposition qui est inacceptable
bruno le maire semble découvrir alors
que ça fait partie des négociations
qu'il mène depuis quatre ans avec la
commission européenne donc sur ce point
là il faut assumer que nous soyons en
capacité de produire de l'électricité
est peut-être plus que d'autres et par
conséquent il faut arrêter avec toutes
ces questions de commission de la
concurrence qui nous bride en quelque
sorte jeu sur le portefeuille des
français puisque vous le disait il ya
les prix de l'essence et les prix du gaz
et les prix de l'électricité est ce que
les socialistes dont la discussion
budgétaire qui arrivent vont proposer
des mesures pour compenser cette missive
à tournefeuille mets proposés c'est
qu'ils ont proposés je sais que le débat
à l'assemblée nationale n'intéresse plus
personne sauf vous parce que vous êtes
au coeur du parlement mais je vous
assure chaque année on fait un contre
budget sa médiation de l'année et ça
veut dire qu'on fait un exercice en dix
ans avec le même argent on peut faire
autre mais on le suit mais là qu'est ce
que vous allez proposer cette fois ci on
va proposer le budget de la première
majorité
de juin 2022 à l'assemblée nationale
donc on construit un budget comme si dès
juin prochain nous étions en
responsabilité et évidemment sur cette
question de l'énergie du soutien à
l'énergie on fera un petit peu
différemment mais il y aura un soutien
parce qu'on peut pas choisir vivre et
comment ça sera pas le shaq émerger on a
également une parfaite élargie mais il
faut aussi qu'on puisse avoir un effet
sur les prix qui se voit aussi pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens donc ça
fait partie des réflexions que nous
sommes encore en train de finaliser mais
oui on sait très bien que l'énergie tout
on a besoin d'énergie dans le monde bon
donc la question de la production
d'énergie est les clés à la fois pour
soutenir notre capacité industrielle et
puis tout simplement pour vivre donc
quand tout le monde a besoin d'énergie
il va y avoir des tensions sur les prix
et il faut être véritablement de façon
très moteur sur la capacité à produire
de l'énergie vous savez quand je dis que
le plan de relance dont ils fonctionnent
pas du gouvernement parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'effet d'entraînement moi je pense
qu'il faut je le redis je l'avais déjà
dit sur cette antenne mais il faut
privilégier cinq secteurs et parmi ces
cinq secteurs il ya la question de
l'énergie qui est quand même
relativement absente de ce que propose
le gouvernement sur la question de
l'énergie donc on sait que tout le monde
l'énergie est bien les prix vont pas
baisser comme ça qu'est ce qu'il y aura
dans votre budget qu est ce que ça sera
le pilier de ce premier budget de la
majorité si vous êtes élue il ya un plan
de relance qui ressemble à quelque chose
autour de cinq secteurs enfin qu'il soit
efficace c'est à dire qu'avec un bras
effet d'entraînement sur l'énergie les
transports la santé l'agriculture la
sécurité numérique aujourd'hui sur les
cloud etc on est complètement
très effacé pour pas dire autre chose
vis-à-vis de puissance mais états unis
et la chine donc ça c'est à une partie
évidemment relance une partie soutient
aux anciennes aux enseignants une partie
soutien au pouvoir d'achat de manière
très ciblée notamment vis-à-vis des
français qui ont subi le plus de pouvoir
et une charte économie nous partie
réduction de la dépense publique alors
sur la partie vous vous attaquez
toujours sur la réduction de la dépense
publique moi je suis pas sous fait quand
même un bon jour parce que
c'est un sujet qui compte c'est le
déficit c'est donc c'est à dire une
désigna d'équations entre vos recettes
et vos dépenses tout le monde parle de
dépenses publiques mais c'est vraiment
l'inadéquation entre les deux il est
évident que nous nous proposons de
rétablir les sf et de taxer la même
façon 1 euros de revenus qui proviennent
de votre cas de votre votre capital qui
travaillent ou qui proviennent de votre
travail avec ça vous avez 20 milliards
sur un quinquennat en plus et est vital
pour le reste on estime que la priorité
c'est de sortir de la crise et donc
effectivement il y aura une partie qui
sera financée par la dette mais vous
aurez observer que le gouvernement fait
lui tout financé par la dette ce qui est
un tout petit peu différent ce qui veut
dire que votre contre budget ou premier
budget du futur quinquennat que vous
proposez sera aussi rappelé que celui du
gouvernement sauf qui sera pas basé sur
la dette mais sur le recours au
financement par les sf c'est ça non mais
il ya le ciel le fait pas le maintien le
sfc a pas tout financer
loin de là donc vous n'êtes pas sûr vous
êtes sur les mêmes chiffres que le
budget proposé les mêmes chiffres vous
considérez que c'est la dépense publique
qui est proposé est trop forte
la dépense publique est mal ciblés tels
que propose le gouvernement je considère
que le budget actuel est un budget à
troupes ce que le gouvernement a fait
plein d'annonce budget a troué un budget
politique aussi là aussi on est dans la
campagne pour vous mais non mais c'est
vous fait des annonces c'est pas dans le
budget donc ces annonces n'ont aucune
existence le plan marseille 1 milliard 5
qui n'est pas dans le budget on est dans
la cour les 22 donc si les pannes en
bugey il n'existe pas pour qu'il puisse
exister faut qu'ils aient des crédits
ouverts s'il est pas dans budget
n'existent pas alors laurent saint
martin qu'elle rapporteur général du
budget qui appartient à la majorité est
dit mais que tout ça sera rajoutée au
cours de l'adoption à faire il peut
importe qu'on le connaisse avant ou
après
c'est un peu un peu nos meilleurs oui
alors je vais donc dans ce cas comme il
aura voté l'article liminaires et qui ne
pourra pas corriger les déficits publics
il va ajouter des dépenses sans corriger
le montant du déficit public donc là
c'est très un sincère et peut-être que
le conseil constitutionnel le rappellera
à l'ordre à pau et si tel était le cas
cela voudrait dire que le budget serait
cassée et qu'on n'aurait pas de budget
au 1er janvier 2022 dont je ne souhaite
pas mais vous voyez bien que c'est quand
même une sacrée cuisine voire une
tambouille qui est inacceptable quand on
parle de milliards d'euros parce que des
milliards d'euros c'est l'argent des
français c'est l'argent de leurs impôts
et je pense qu'on leur doit un minimum
de lisibilité de clarté et de sincérité
un mot sur un autre sujet qui pourrait
toucher au portefeuille des français
c'est cette histoire de pneus neige ça
va rentrer en application le 1er
novembre dans 48 départements dont le
votrient le tarn et garonne est concerné
sauf que le préfet apparemment éthique
dans le tarn-et-garonne aucune commune
pourrait ne pourraient être concernées
c'est assez
l'appréciation du préfet est ce que vous
vous approuvé ce choix du préfet oui les
48 départements sont ceux qui ont des
communes en zone montagne dans mon
département j'ai 100 95 communes dont
deux qui sont classés en zone montagne
feneyrols et ginals la neige la dernière
fois qu'on en a eu c'était en janvier 22
ans dans janvier 2012 pardon donc oui le
préfet raison mais la loi est très
claire elle à elle donne la possibilité
au préfet de dire c'est applicable ou
pas applicable et de dire dans quelle
commune c'est applicable c'est pas
forcément applicable sur tout le
département donc la loi est assez
souvent alors je vois bien que sacré
beau coup de main dire de
houleux débats comprenez ces réactions
je les comprends parce qu'effectivement
des pneus neige ça coûte quand même un
peu d'argent et que très peu de français
et que je pense que peu de français en
sont équipés après que la loi disent il
faut quand même éviter notamment en
montagne d'avoir des risques et de
prendre des risques que ça c'est logique
mais honnêtement il ya une souplesse qui
est laissée je vous dis moi sur 195
commune y en a deux qui sont classés en
zone montagne ce qui fait tout le
département potentiellement devraient
avoir l'obligation de porter des pneus
neige et que le préfet 10 buts ça va pas
être le cas bon j approuve la décision
de la préfète en l'occurrence et une
préfète on termine avec une question sur
la crise sanitaire et les vagues autre
sujet oui la crise sanitaire et le parti
socialiste toujours partisan d'une
obligation vaccinale oui non et comment
est ce que ça pourrait se faire
concrètement alors concrètement quand on
l'a proposé au mois de juillet nous
avions mis un principe l'obligation de
se vacciner pour tous parce que nous
craignons qu'il y ait une stigmatisation
des soignants ce qui d'ailleurs a été un
peu le cas et nous pensions qu avoir un
principe universel c'est toujours mieux
que m impasse des contrôles externes et
a donc nous avions dit on par 2 juillet
jusqu'au 1er octobre les caisses
primaires d'assurance-maladie appel 16
et ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés c'est
facile à savoir avec votre numéro de
sécurité sociale les convaincre certains
ont des questions ou en d'autres ne
veulent absolument pas et vaccinés on le
sait et on fait bilan au 1er octobre et
ce qui compte c'est d'avoir une immunité
collective et pour avoir une immunité
collective il faut qu'il y ait 85 90 %
de la population qu'ils soient vaccinés
on atteint ce chiffre là au 1er octobre
mais dans ce cas on a atteint l'objectif
souhaité est plutôt que de stigmatiser
des personnes plutôt que d'être dans la
sanction donc nous on était plutôt sur
ce principe là là effectivement on va
tirer un bilan au 1er octobre de tout ce
et c'est ce qu'ils ont les double dose
enfin qui sont complètement vaccinés et
voir si cette immunité collective et
atteindre mais si on ne sera pas mais on
n'y sera pas on est bien d'accord on y
serait sur la relégation avec ce maïs
curan débat est vieux c'est ma le 13
octobre à ce jeu c'est bien mais c'est
ce que j'attends ce mais on lundi un
sénateur qui nous disent on est pas
content sur le principe voté ce texte
mais dans la méthode on comprend pas
très bien comment faut il appliquer un
traitement oui sauf que sauf que ce oui
j'entends bien leurs questions sauf que
nous nous voulions commencer au mois de
juillet et que les caisses primaires
d'assurance-maladie appelle toutes
celles et tous ceux qui sont pas
vaccinés ça n'a pas été le cas pendant
l'été vous savez donc en fait cette
phase de pédagogie elle n'a pas été mené
à son terme peut-être qu'il faut se dire
si la proposition est votée on se dit
jusqu'au 15 novembre où on peut penser
le temps qu'il faut à la caisse pris aux
caisses primaires d'assurance maladie
mais ce travail la pédagogie n'a pas été
fait c'était ça la méthode proposée en
juillet c'était vraiment une méthode
c'est de convaincre et pas de
sanctionner merci beaucoup merci à vous
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
[Musique]